[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb thank you for tuning
in we've had some great guests and I I
got to tell you we got great guests
coming up um all I'll say is if you
really like the podcast this little
podcast that we're bringing you every
week and hopefully you're enjoying um I
ask you to follow us and maybe write a
review if you want but most importantly
give the show a chance and um subscribe
and uh the Ryan you can tell them where
the what the handles are at inside of
you podcast on Instagram and Facebook
and inside of you pod on Twitter I will
not call it X it is Twitter I won't
either I'm going to call it Twitter uh a
lot of things happening in in the world
but uh we don't need to bore you with
that um what I will say is that um well
we're enjoying this podcast and we
really appreciate it and uh thank thanks
for uh all the uh love and uh thanks to
my patrons uh for giving back to the
show to keep the it going you can go to
patreon p a r o n.com inside of you if
you want to give back to the show at all
and that's patreon.com inside of you
also the inside you online store has a
bunch of merch um lexith scripts and
ship keys and cool stuff like that
pictures and and you know they're
autographed by me because uh well they
just are also you can go to my Instagram
at theic rosenbom go to my link tree you
can see my the cons I'm going to the
Cameo uh all that stuff all the news
it's all there and I really appreciate
it and
uh yeah go to sunspin
docomo it's called Rosy's puppy fresh
breath and you can get it on Amazon and
it's really awesome it's got the picture
of me and my dogs and uh Rosy's puppy
fresh breath and it's it's cool you just
put like a little right you just put a
little uh dab like in the cap and you
put it in the dog's water and the
instructions are there that's it and my
dog's breath I use it every day and
their breath great and it's odorless
it's uh tasteless I was going to ask you
for some the other day really uh because
I'm watching my sister's dog and it's
bad breath no he got into uh some feces
on our walk oh no yeah cuz he he's very
good he's a scavenger like he like he
he'll pick up anything he thinks is food
on the ground and the breath is just
awful and he just got into some poop
I'll get you one yeah I'll get you one
of those they might need it cuz he's
like if you don't get him fast enough
he'll so easy and there's other products
out there that do it too but you know I
like our product and the label's nice
and pretty and it works most importantly
so go to Amazon it's called Rosy's puppy
fresh breath if you want to write a
review that'd be awesome uh that's up to
you uh today we have a guest that had
was on just about a year ago and he was
so good that had to have him back on
because he's so fun he's so interesting
his Clips went viral he is a uh super
talented actor and cool cool dude a tell
all sort of um you know doesn't take
much [__] from a lot of people and uh
but he's a big sweetheart he really is
he's got a heart of gold and I loved
having him on the podcast and now we've
got him back it's Michael bean I think
you know Michael bean look him up for
God's sakes I don't need to give you his
credits they speak for themselves right
Ryan yeah they really do they really
really do I wish I had his career uh
let's get inside of my good buddy
Michael Bean it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rose
[Music]
B inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience what I was saying to you
is I I had not done very many podcasts
before but I had done Adam Cora's
podcast right a couple of times years
ago and my son used to produce this show
and um
I don't ever remember people approaching
me on the street going hey Adam Cora
fantastic or whatever but since I've
done your show I've had like 30 people
35 40 people just come up to you they
just come up to me and like I saw you on
Rosen bomb show man you that was great
awesome you know love that uh and I'm
I'm really surprised you have a much
bigger
following uh Loy I loyal following well
I I don't know if I'm sure you know your
audience so I'm sure they're loyal but
uh yeah it's it was it's been kind of
crazy yeah you called me and I was like
what you like people you know and it's
not only that but other actors in the
industry colleagues and whatnot they
were they were coming up to me saying
dude your interview with Michael Bean
that's I mean they that's the go-to they
keep coming back to that they like you a
lot and they liked what's his name um
that you liked what was the older guy
Robert Patrick yeah I like Robert it was
the same thing it was two guys who were
just laying it out there who were real
dudes yeah and I think what people got
from you and you could tell me about
this is James Cameron said you are a
monster star and you could be a huge
major star but you didn't want to do a
lot of publicity you didn't like that
whole part of the thing you want you
were about the work is that true um yeah
and I think I alluded to that um yeah
you know there's a skill to being able
to do the red carpet and go on the
morning shows and do that like 60-second
clip and all that stuff and uh you know
you go shoot the magazines and you're on
the cover of magazines and they do
stories about you and uh I was just
never that comfortable I just was never
comfortable doing that stuff and like I
told you last time my lifestyle was one
in which um you know I didn't you know
uh if if people were following me around
with cameras
uh they they would have gotten quite a
show back in the day you know really you
didn't really talk about that did you I
did yeah of course I talked about all my
boozing well I know about the boozing
and stuff but like on camera like when
people were trying to film you and stuff
were you like aggressive no I was
uncomfortable or you know if team Z jump
out at me I could be u a little bit
aggressive but um no I was just
uncomfortable I just didn't feel you
know I'm an actor and I this format is
different than somebody just coming up
shoving a camera in your face and you
know asking you about your movie or you
know about something that's going on and
uh um I I just never very felt very
comfortable doing it there's a
difference between between being an
actor and a movie star and some people
can do it really well you know um Tom
Hanks does it really well and Johnny
Depp does it really well and there's you
know a lot of people that do it really
is it the nerves it's kind of I yeah I
don't feel comfortable I just don't feel
comfortable I feel I love acting I so
you never felt comfortable someone
coming Mr pan get an interview with you
you're like no thanks no well you know
it's not like I you know sometimes you
have to do press for a movie you have to
you know you have to be there to do
press they call junkets and whatnot
press junk oh yeah I've done plenty of
junk and those don't make you feel
comfortable no I've never felt
comfortable doing that cuz you think
what is it is it the [__] is it the
sort of surfaced crap it's just a
natural thing I don't I don't
feel
um I don't feel like myself you know I
don't feel like this is you know
and I feel like I've got to like oh got
to promote the movie and you know [__]
all that [__] you know and I and I you
know you you were asking me before and I
didn't articulate it as well as I could
have is I've never thought about being a
movie star I never my dreams when I came
over here were so minor what were your
dreams if somebody had told if somebody
had told me that I could have been in a
soap opera for 20 years and gotten paid
$100,000 a year I would have sold my
soul for it at that really you just
wanted to act you I you know I you know
when I got my screen actor gu car when I
got my first like modeling gig when I
got my first commercials all of that
stuff was like oh my God you know I do a
photo shoot for some car company and it
would be in Playboy magazine and I'd run
back and show my parents and stuff like
that you know just a just a a modeling
job but I was not a runway model you
know I was not really no no I was not um
just uh I I think they call it like a
print you know print right print model I
could see I could never I was never I'm
not being you know self-deprecating I am
but like I was never good-looking enough
to be a model a print model magazines I
never book commercials I never I just I
was like an awkward looking kid so if
that was presented to me
I wonder I wonder what I would have done
but if someone like you who just doesn't
like that stuff in the beginning when
you're modeling and stuff on print did
you feel comfortable doing that yeah why
is that cuz youing a I wasn't having to
talk to anybody you know I wasn't having
I wasn't promoting anything I don't know
it was just yeah go stand over there
Smile Smile bigger now start laughing
you know yeah well and of course they
did and at that time
you know Michael I was work I used to
work for the make company a lot which
was they used to run ads in the LA times
and I go down there they they were
paying me $60 an hour and I was this was
back in the you know Mid 7 early early
like 73 74 75 that was huge money for me
huge money for me I do a couple hours
come home with $120 have pay my rent you
know I lived in a I lived in a little
box with three other guys my brother and
uh another friend from uh Arizona and uh
a guy that yeah yeah so I've always you
know Michael as I said before I've
always had a really good time I love
this business I love this business I
love what it's what's happened it
happened my career happened like very
very slowly incremental yeah but people
think of me like oh you did the
Terminator well when I did the
Terminator that you know I was the most
experienced person on that on that uh
crew you know um because you had done
all these other little gigs yeah and
more than little gigs I had done movies
and television shows and a television
series that you know didn't go six years
but I had worked a lot by the time it's
amazing how much experience you get when
you're doing a TV show you if you pay
attention you have everything right
there that you need to prepare you for
the big thing if that happens Stan
Winston talks about reading the
Terminator script and going on oh my God
I got to do this I got to do this
because they originally wanted Dick
Smith who I'd worked with on the fan see
I already did on the fan I'd already
worked with Lauren ball Robert stigwood
Hector
alzando uh Griffith Dunn was in there
you Star Struck it all with Lauren B was
this uh yeah I was a little star struck
but uh was she nice no she wasn't nice
no she's a very she I think she was a
very unhappy person was she nice to you
no and how'd you deal with that um I was
young I didn't um care as much I didn't
you know uh uh no I you know I'm an
actor I don't you know I I don't need
her being friendly with me and you don't
need anybody being friendly we talked
about that with Val Kilmer and all these
other guys in Tombstone you're like I
don't give a [__] you don't want to talk
to me let's do this part let's do it but
you know listen I have a you know I had
a a great time not not only with the
other actors with powers and with Steven
L and with John Corbett and um all the
guys that were Cowboys you know I had a
great time it wasn't like okay we're
just going to do this and [__] [__] the
move you know we we we we had a really
good time Kurt Russell and Val Kilmer
they kind of hooked up
like uh I never
asked I never wanted to know I never
goalie was around her children were
around their children were around they
were a little to not toddlers but
pre-teens that kind of thing at the time
what was I talking about why do you have
I like CU my mind goes all these places
well you're talking about Laur McCall
you had the experience you were you were
prepared so when you did this movie you
know when you did uh Terminator yeah
when I did Terminator I had I had done a
lot of work and Jim had uh done um the
Piranha movie and had been fired off of
that some great stories about Jim
Cameron over there uh recut it he he
used to go into uh uh he got fired off
yeah and he know that yeah he and he was
uh I think it was some Italian company
and uh so after he shot the movie The
Italian guys just thought okay we'll
take it and we'll cut it cut it together
and he used to sneak into The Cutting
Room at night and he used to like recut
what they cut so they'd show up the next
morning and they'd be like what you you
know like and so he kept sneaking in and
Rec every day how you do that well he BR
asked Jim Cameron but that's that for
sure is a a story that's out there and
that uh uh Lance Hendrickson told me he
was working with Lance Hendrickson and
Jim will tell you too that he was in
there and U that's pretty crazy so he
gets fired off this movie yes he's
trying to re-edit and then they give him
Terminator 2 they didn't give him
Terminator 2 he wrote Terminator 2 okay
he didn't nobody gave Jim anything so
they didn't want him to direct
well he has he was working for Roger
corman's company and he wrote a you know
he he wrote this script and
um
uh hemdale uh John Daly and I forget the
name of the other guy and uh uh they
took it out to all the studios nobody
want anything to do with it they took it
to Orion and a guy named Mike medavoy
was running the company at the time and
uh he's got a son now that I think is
still in the business as manager or
agent or something so he he he shopped
it around in Orion yeah yeah yeah nobody
Orion was the only company that was
interested in doing
it inside he was brought to you by
Shopify I don't know what I would do
without Shopify Ryan Shopify is so easy
to use I have two stores that I have now
through Shopify I have the inside you
online store I have uh the tville online
store and on Shopify it's so easy you
just go and go it says products and
these are your products add new product
product hit a button add new product how
many sales have you had hit the button
analytics you see the numbers come in
what's your best seller everything is so
easy to look at to use and adding
products and and and it's just like I
never thought it would be this easy I
thought it would be a real pain and you
don't have to do much of anything it
keeps track of everything for you
Shopify is the global Commerce platform
that helps you sell at every stage of
your business from the launch your
online shop stage to the first real life
store stage all the way to the did we
just hit a million orders stage Shopify
is there to help you grow whether you're
selling scented soap or offering outdoor
outfits Shopify helps you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their in-person
POS system wherever and whatever you're
selling shopify's got you covered yes in
Shopify Ryan helps you turn browsers
into buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 30 36% better
compared to other leading Commerce
platforms and sell more with less effort
thanks to Shopify magic your AI powered
Allstar Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the US and Shopify is the
global force behind all birds rothy and
Brook linen and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries plus shopify's extensive help
resources are there to support your
success every step of the way because
businesses that grow grow grow with
Shopify sign up for a $1 per month trial
period at shopify.com inside all
lowercase go to shopify.com insid now to
grow your business no matter what stage
you're in shopify.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by
wondery being a king or queen might seem
enticing but more often than not it
comes at the expense of everything else
like your freedom your private Y and
sometimes even your head the creators of
Wes even the rich are bringing you a
brand new podcast called even the Royals
where host Brooke and Arisha pull back
the curtain on royal families past and
present from all over the world to show
you the darker side of what it means to
be royalty from stories about one of the
most infamous Royals in history Marie
Antoinette but everything you know about
her is wrong after she became Queen at
just 19 years old she ended up in a
battle with the French press and started
a series of impossible to believe events
it's History's Greatest smear campaign
and it had deadly consequences or what
might be the worst Royal marriage of all
time between King George IV and Caroline
of Brunswick it's a story involving
catfishing fake pregnancies and It All
Leads to a divorce trial where the whole
world sat on the edge of their seats to
see how it would all play out follow
even the Royals on the wry app or
wherever you get your podcast you can
binge even the royal add free right now
on wry
plus they said if you can get a star to
be in it then you know we'll green light
it a star of a certain magnitude which I
was not I had worked a lot but I wasn't
a and still have never really been a
movie star but uh and you can you can go
online and find out about and listen to
Jim and Arnold talk about how they met
and uh how you know they decided that he
would Play the Terminator and that freed
him up now he had as a big star because
he uh uh Arnold was already Mr Universe
and been Mr Universe for like five or
six so he was a and he had done cone in
the Barbarian he had done the first cone
in the Barbarian and U you know he he
and and so he was a star but he was not
somebody that I as a young actor you
know I was like watching dairo and
Pacino and Dustin Hoffman and Warren
batty and Jack Lemon those were your
guys well yeah I mean that's you looked
up to you aspired to be yeah especially
daero you know Taxi Driver changed my
life tax the movie Taxi Driver turned me
into a different turned me into I want
to be like that guy I want to be like
that just because of the raw a it's it's
a brilliant movie it's it's the best of
the best as far as I scor say you go he
didn't win the Academy Award for that
but he it uh the score the the all
Jody
Foster but dairo in it is just
stunningly brilliant were you
intimidated by his performance or like
no I want to do that I do I want to do
that I wasn't intimidated by I know I
really don't get intimidated by anybody
you know one actor that you go God man I
I can't do what he does there's a lot of
actors that that that I can't do what
they do but if I'm I never claimed to do
that so you know I'm not intimidated I'm
just like okay well I'm me so um I can
do this and that's you know that's what
I do so I met dairo once because he used
to stay at the Mayflower Hotel in New
York City which is no longer there and I
was there with my uh wife at the time or
girlfriend wife my first wife and uh
where I was at a restaurant and I was
sitting there and I was like [__]
Robert Dao's oh my God it's Robert dairo
Robert Deno honey that's Robert dairo
sitting over there you know and I was
like you know and uh dairo looks up and
uh he looks over at my my table he looks
over at me and he goes like this come on
come on over here what I was like what I
said H that's had you done anything at
this point uh yeah I was doing the fan
okay I was shooting the fan at the time
and he stay he I think he had like a
permanent place at the Mayflower Hotel
and I was staying at the Mayflower Hotel
and and but I hadn't seen him around the
hotel come over here that's exact that's
exactly what yeah yeah yeah very good
yeah very good and uh I was like oh my
God you know what you know what
couldt what could he possibly say to me
I went over there and he was with like a
little a little group and uh two or
three guys and he said uh that that girl
you I can't I can't do I can't do
Impressions who that girl you yeah yeah
yeah is that your sister he
says I'm like I'm like uh no Bobby no uh
no I said no Mr Dino that's that's my
wife and uh oh I get the [__] back to
the table exactly that was my experience
and then my then my wife ended up
setting him up with one of her
girlfriends and he went out with one of
her girlfriends who was from New York
and that didn't go very well but you
didn't hang out with him after that
really no no I've never seen him again
let me ask you this when Orion is it
Orion or orian or when Orion bought
Terminator when they're casting was it
like was there like did James want you
no yeah I went
in along with probably a lot of other
people I think originally he wanted
sting because he thought sting had this
kind of unearthly quality about him and
I think he met with sting and I think
sting basically said uh yeah I just
watched piranha too I think I'll take a
pass on this then you know um some
something along something along those
lines I'm not sure how serious Jim was
about him I've never heard any other
name associated uh with kyes right um
but you know I uh was doing I was
actually U uh rehearsing for a play for
a guy named Jose quento back in the day
it was cat on a Hunton roof and I was
not rehearsing I was uh auditioning but
I auditioned with like a number of
different women and um I was there for
six 7even hours auditioning and then I
went and auditioned for Jim and Gail
herd and Gail herd doesn't really get
the recognition that I think that she
deserves because it's you know Jim Jim
Jim camera Jim camera but she produced
Terminator aliens and and the abyss you
love the abys I love the abyss well the
abyss is um the abyss I think Jim has
described the abyss uh uh you know the
first two acts are extraordinary well
what happens in that movie is the
brilliant scene where Mary Elizabeth
Master Antonio and um uh Ed Harris are
uh trying to decide the water's Rising
on them they're trying to decide you
wear the helmet no I'll wear you wear
the helmet you wear the helmet the
water's rising up they finally decide
he's going to wear the helmet pull her
underwater and then they're going to
bring her back to life which they did
and he's on top of her wake up you [__]
and he's slapping her and all the his
group is around him and it's a
tremendous
film it's I mean a tremendous um uh
scene and it it it it it brings the
audience and all the characters to a
place
emotionally that he that Jim never
achieves with the rest of the movie so
the emotional high for the characters
and the emotional high for the uh uh the
the the audience happens Peaks at that
point now does he admit to that has he
said that yes I've heard him say that
there's a uh but this is not even going
to be like the old Abyss he when when he
was shooting the abyss he brought me in
and he showed me he had two endings he
had one that was three hours long and he
had one that was a truncated sort of you
know version of what the studio wanted
him to um release and that's what he
released and this is going to be longer
and it's going to have um
more depth uh well I don't you know I
don't I don't I don't know I I kind of
saw it in a rough cut and and I can't
tell you uh uh I have you talked to him
at all no I haven't talked to Jim in uh
four years you know he moved to New
Zealand he's in New Zealand now and he's
been there for a while he's not up in he
was up in Malibu for years and years and
years and the last time I was in his
office is it was when I was doing um uh
Mandalorian Mandalorian and and him
shooting the same same lot and uh and
you just went to visit him yeah he was
editing and he was like yeah come on in
yeah so if you saw him it'd be like
yesterday yeah with with with Jim
Cameron I'm the
same
person yeah yeah of course and and I
don't you know I don't think Jim Cameron
has changed he's a billionaire now but
yeah but he's always been that guy every
time you see him do an interview and
he's talking about some camera lens or
some effect
you can't even understand like when that
that that that underwater thing that
went down to the Titanic explod imploded
yeah that's what happened to me in the
abyss the exact same you know like my
character is one of my best death scenes
I think is my characters like freaking
out the windows cracking and that and
that
submersible implodes doesn't explode it
implodes and that's what happened to
them and you know Jim came out and I
heard him talking about that but uh and
Jim was in town a couple weeks ago
announcing this uh uh 4K whatever that
means yeah hi de what yeah there's 5K
now I believe go back to when you were
cast you auditioned for 7 hours well no
I was auditioning for uh
kattin so was a lot more material and I
was I was working with different
actresses they were mixing and matching
us doing all that kind of stuff so when
I went to do the uh audition for Cameron
um I did an audition they said thank you
very much I went back and my agent
called me and said they like you they
like you very much they like your but
they they don't like the fact that
you're Southern that you're you have
this Regional sort of southern accent
I'm like I'm Southern what I I'm from
Nebraska I'm what do you ah oh this is
what happened yeah the thing just kind
of followed me to the next audition
which I had just rushed to that's not
method there's nothing Methodist like I
don't even know what that was Stanis lki
and but you were so into it that you
probably had a little bit of a draw
something was left over so they said
well bring him back and let you know
because we like him I brought him back
and I read for him and Gail again and I
got the part and then did you know you
got the part in the room no no that
rarely ever happens like thank you thank
you very much you know not like thank
you thank you very much say hey M all
right Michael you you know I I don't
remember exactly but Jim has always been
very personable with me you know and and
gaale too very professional very did he
give you a lot of Direction in that
movie I don't think I don't remember him
what he does Michaels he writes a great
script he writes he writes great
dialogue come with me if you want to
live you know he writes great dialogue
and so uh if you if you have great
dialogue and you cast an actor that you
want to say those words there's not I
don't you know I don't ever remember s
sitting around discussing character
background you know like all that like
you're when you get in there you you
know the part you're the part well I
didn't you know I like to do research if
I'm playing a cop I like to hang around
cops seal I've hung around a bunch of
Navy SEALs for that piece of [__] if the
script is good you should be same with
Tombstone you know they didn't you know
it's the it's the let me say something
about Tombstone now because I get so so
eff and tired of people ask me if Kurt
Russ director the movie okay Kurt
Russell did not direct the movie okay
Kurt Russell was responsible for getting
the movie off the ground I never would
have played Johnny Ringo if it wasn't
for Kurt Russell and I told you last
time I was here I love Kurt Russell and
he's a great great person and I and I
and a great movie star um he's a movie
star who's handles it really well you
know uh but he's he didn't direct the
movie no it was directed uh by
kind of a a committee you know we talked
about George cosmatos who came in to
replace Kevin jars so Kevin Char shoots
five weeks they throw all that stuff
away and then um uh George M George
cosmatos takes over and he's kind of a
visual guy and we shoot for another
month or two six weeks or something like
that and then they then they then then
they they go into post and when you go
into post post you you know you edit the
movie it was edited by a good good
editor but uh I know that Kurt
immediately right after that movie went
on to do a movie called Stargate that
they made the television series out of
right so they they did Stargate and he
cuz I went to visit him on the set like
a week after we wrapped the movie and he
was already doing Stargate but watch him
and anybody watch Kurt Russell in in
Stargate and he's so grumpy
and angry is that from Tombstone the
residual effect I you know that's the
way that I you know when I saw the movie
I thought like I've never seen him so
grumpy before you know did you not
remember him being grumpy on the set of
Tom oh he was no he was never on no no
he's fun he was like like I said he's
got a great laugh he has a lot of fun uh
but what I was saying to you before is
like him and Val kind of bonded so it
was him and Val that they kind of used
to hang out too so you know that that
happens on movies um but you said he
didn't direct it he didn't direct it was
directed by committee I mean it was a
great everybody had a hand in like
vision and stuff everybody had a hand in
it but you know a lot of the stuff got
cut out of the movie uh before we got a
chance to shoot it well here it is I'll
be able to find it now oh I like the
glasses you know I got I had some
started having some problems well
you're with my eyes no but not looking
just like pain and uh yeah I went to my
uh I went to my doctor and he sent me to
an ey guy and the guy said like he
looked at me and did all the tests and
everything oh you got the Johnny Deb
disease and I was like you're too
good-looking no he just said you got the
Johnny Depp disease you got to wear
sungrass glasses the rest of your life
I'm like oh oh do really do I have to
he's like yep I and that's that's what I
yeah I don't even know Johnny Depp had a
disease where asked to wear sunglasses
all the time what's it called believe so
the Johnny Depp disease that's what my
my the JD my doctor called I'm going to
I'm going to say I have the Michael Bean
disease I'm going to start wearing
[__]
sunglasses you know you wear sunglasses
at night it's the only time I get
recognized anymore is if I wear
sunglasses at night he must be a movie
star or is Cory Hart I wear my sun
glasses at night I know that you that
you saw the movie a long time ago but
for people who know that movie
well um
uh I'm just [__] around about the
glasses that wasn't true no are you
kidding me no so you don't have a Johnny
Depp disease no but there's no such
thing actually I believed it didn't you
Ryan [__] you I think he I think Johnny
Deb does have some sort of disease I
don't know call it a disease got me dude
and you got the audience it's going to
be like all over the
he's got the Johnny de thing you [__] I
totally bought that Jack Nicholson had
it too right well I've got some Johnny
Depp [__] that I contracted back in the
80s you're good you're a good
impressionist thanks so anyway um there
were certain things that got cut from
the F before we had a chance to shoot
them because when they brought in George
cosmatos and they threw out all of
Kevin's uh footage they had to condense
145 page script which you know is 2 and
1 half two 2 hours and 45 minutes down
to something that ended up being 90
minutes long and if you ask Kurt Kurt
back uh 10 years ago talked about the
fact that he had kind of had to hollow
out his character and uh uh to give you
know a lot of his stuff he had to cut
out to make sure that the movie worked
and made sense in that time well it made
sense to him I don't really remember it
that way I remember the the boys getting
the [__] kicked out of them on on that
cut it was according to Val Kilmer was
it was Val Kilmer and Kurt Russell who
edited what scenes were going to be in
the movie and what scenes weren't going
to be in the movie and a guy named John
fosado John something where they came in
he was a director but he kind of came in
to piece it all together do you believe
that do you believe that Val and and
Kirk kind of dictated that oh they did
no Val said it I've seen Val is a
uh yeah so they went in the editing room
and and cut this [__] down because it
was a biger fight they they had to they
had to because uh it was what it was a
long movie it was going to be a you know
a a two and a half hour movie at least
it love to see that well there's nothing
there because they cut the they cut it
before we shot it so it's not like
there's a bunch of you know yeah there's
not like there's a bunch of footage
sitting someplace else that they didn't
cut they cut shoot
it this show is sponsored by betterhelp
guys you don't need me to sit here and
talk to you about this but I'm going to
um you know how important therapy is
this podcast talks about mental health
and well-being and and all that other
stuff and it's it's so important to me
in my lifestyle now that it's helped me
substantially I know it's helped
millions of other people and better help
is a huge part of that um it's
affordable therapy online where you can
change your therapist like that if you
don't like them or don't feel like
they're the right fit um it's it's so
easy to use you fill out a questionnaire
that takes barely any time and you're
ready to go and it's the new year so if
you've got things we've got things we
need to talk about um better help is is
there Ryan around new years's right we
get obsessed on how to change ourselves
instead of just expanding on what we're
already doing right I I do it I write a
New Year's resolution I write all these
things and you know maybe you finally
organized one part of your space and you
want to tackle another or maybe you're
you're taking your supplements every
morning right now you want to actually
eat breakfast too whatever your goals
are for the new year therapy helps you
find your strengths so you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick I'm telling you when I
stick to therapy it's better it's life
is better and what happens is I used to
do this where oh feeling good now I
don't need therapy it's like not
changing your oil every couple months or
it's like not these are
Necessities that if you stop doing
something it's gonna you know what I
mean I think it's just really important
look if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule even if you've added some new
routines in there just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge why
wait for a new year when you can
celebrate you and the changes you've
already made right now therapy from
better help can get you there and help
you love you love the journey love this
new year celebrate the progress you've
already made visit betterhelp.com insid
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
inside so Ringo uh um you you know yeah
me uh the only time you ever see the
Cowboys is when they're with the hers
all right that was not like the script
at all okay there was a bunch of cowboy
stuff uh that kind of evened it out a
little bit more and one of the um this
is a scene that was in the original
script that
um that is Ringo and this is
after uh Curly Bill broches has been
killed Po's boo has been killed right
and so I take over that's kind of like
set up earlier God knows what is going
to happen when Johnny Ringo takes over
this group so I'm taking over and one of
the Cowboys uh who was at the scene
where Curly Bill is killed was talk talk
is talk about why talking about Wyatt
her right right and uh uh like oh my God
he was just you know shooting the
bullets were missing him and if you know
the movie people know what I'm talking
about
and uh people love that movie and and so
Ringo says to him he's just a man and
the cowboy says to me you didn't see his
face and Ringo says you see my face
don't you everybody get this through
their heads Wyatt her
dies I'm running the show now and I'm
telling you her dies his men too they
all
die understand we're going to kill him
you hear me for what they did to Curly
Bill we're going to ride him into the
ground and Slaughter him like rabbits
cuz this is my time
children this is my time to get
woolly I cut that [__] out before I
shot it how pissed were you I was too
busy uh servicing the her wives movie
that was awesome I would have loved to
seen that dude I wanted more of your
character I really did I mean it was
like the thing that sold me was that gun
thing which we talked about in the last
one but it's like you know when you do
that thing in front of Val and like you
know and you I'm like oh this guy's
bigger than life Larger than Life and he
believes it he believes that he's Larger
than Life that he's better than
everybody else that he's course but that
that's badass I be like [__] you let me
at least do it you're an actor and you
get a script and you go like okay well
this a great scene this a great scene oh
this this the best scene in the movie
that was the best scene in the movie for
Johnny Ringo I never got to shoot it did
you learn the lines uh no like I said I
was too busy servicing the her wise to
pay much attention to what was what was
going on oh my God you know what's funny
is like in the very beginning of this
conversation we're talking about you're
like I never wanted to be a movie star
you know you got Tom Hy you I love
acting I wanted to act but you know
you're the only person that's been that
has said that that I believe I actually
believe that you didn't [__] believe
it no I do I do believe from the passion
the conviction I see it I never thought
I never dreamt I would be a movie star I
never you know my what I did you did and
a lot of people do a lot of people think
yeah you know I knew I knew by the time
I was six what I wanted to do I wanted
to be a no I I just I was just looking
you know I was looking to uh uh
pay my bills always and and I ran into
Jim Cameron and I was lucky enough to do
a really good audition for Jim Cameron
which led to aliens which led to the
abyss which then leads to offers on
Tombstone and I did a but almost I
mentioned the last time I was here from
the time I auditioned for Jim
Cameron the next time I auditioned and
got a job was a movie called clock
Stoppers at uh and youve had the guy on
who directed it I can't think of his
name at the moment the guy from Star
Wars um uh not not Star Trek John John
jonan Franks Jonathan Franks directed
it's a good little movie but he's a
great guy isn't he love him love him
love him absolutely that was the first
audition you had and what year was that
that was that that that was there were
17 years between the time that I
auditioned for the Terminator and and
the time that I did audition for clock
stop cuz my career was going offer only
though offer only yeah but I did go in
for a few things in audition and and I
didn't get and um uh so uh did you
audition for James Cameron after the
first time no never again well you know
I replaced James Remar on yeah we didn't
really talk about that did we no but you
know it's out there it's out there but
long story short James Remar kind of
flew into England or whatever for the
movie and then he got busted for drugs
yes and they fired him off the movie yes
and they had already been shooting they
had been shooting for about a week and
they found drugs in his hotel room and
England wanted him um out of out of the
country and I was at home and I was
aware of the movie but you know I knew
that that that he was doing it he was
close to Walter Hill cuz he did the
Warriors and so um and he's a nice guy
love the Warriors um so yeah I got a
call on Thursday or Friday from from
Gail herd and she said Michael we're uh
we're replacing uh Remar can you come
over here and and play the role of hicks
I didn't have to think about that for
any longer than about a split second
before I you know said yes and I was you
know I got on a plane they gave me got
got got me the script I got on a plane I
was in the set Monday morning you filmed
Monday Monday morning yeah were you
nervous [__] no I'd worked I'd worked I
see I'd worked with Jim before first of
all Hicks doesn't have that much to say
the guy in the tournament
all the who the Terminator is who the uh
who she is what her future is who I am
you know like I've got all the
exposition and James Cameron is smart
enough to put all that Exposition in all
these car chases and stuff so it it
works but if you look at Hicks he's
sleep half the time you know he's you it
says a word here and a word there and I
came in and I had already been working
with Jim and I with Gale and I'd done by
that time I knew Bill Paxton very well
we talked about Bill PA before and Bill
and I were very close back then uh and
that was right after you met Louise but
we were we we had a great time over
there but we were still seeing each
other all the time and our careers
weren't taking us so you were
comfortable already on that set very
pretty comfortable yeah was there anyone
on that set and sorne is great too sour
and soury loved you right she praised
your performance I mean
like that's that's a performance that's
so you play it with such ease and like
sensitivity and such likability it's one
of those roles that I always I look at
I'm like I love this guy I want to be
this guy this guy's the [__] coolest
and and you know watching that do you
when's the last time are you one that
watches the movies you're in maybe after
do you watch them later on years later
you do when's the last time you saw
aliens uh oh I
haven't I've seen parts of aliens
probably in the last six months but I've
seen aliens aliens the best movie I've
ever been in without a doubt aliens is
the best movie did you think it would be
well we had High Hopes cuz Jim had done
the Terminator and the sets were
incredible and you know a good script
when you see one so yes did we have high
hopes we had like yeah very very high
hopes but you never know there's a great
book called The Devil's candy about
making can bonfire the vanities and how
they thought they had something so
special back then and uh Bruce Willis
and they fired Morgan Freeman off of it
that's how great they thought this thing
was and they thought it was great you
know and but everybody's invested in it
you know the actors are invested the
directors invested the crews invested
the producers are invested the studi
invested so everybody's you know
invested in it and they all thought they
had the best movie you know going
Academy Awards right down the line and
it came out people hated it it's
terrible and it's a great book called
Dirty candy so you never really know if
a if a movie is going to be uh well
regarded successful until you put it in
front of an audience last time I was
here I um I told you that I had done a
couple shows uh last year uh one was in
Australia and one was in Thailand and uh
the one I did in Australia is I I
described it as a monster movie okay and
I about a year and a half ago uh I got a
call and I got an offer for uh a job and
um I I it was you know a decent enough
offer that I needed to to read it and so
or read read enough of it to know
whether it was going to be any good or
not it had a really funky title
it was called zaroo zaro I I have a
feeling zombies are in this movie yeah
okay I'm smart and zaroo shot in
Australia kangaroo zombies there you go
okay so I looked at the title I was like
ah [__] this [__] Shar NATO you know
blah blah blah zaro yeah ridiculous
right so I started reading the script
and I [__] sat I read the script in
one sitting I'm like that this this
script has got good structure this
script this and the character I liked
the character I liked a lot the whole
thing needed some work but I thought
like well this is kind of good so I I
read it again and I read it again and I
um thought like it's good script so um I
told them I was interested I started
getting into contact with the
filmmaker uh Ryan and his partner
Richard and Jud was the producer and we
um you know we started working on the
script we started working on the script
and I'm good at that I'm very very very
good at filmmakers Make Scenes better
make characters better make things make
more sense uh [__] meter you know
like like that doesn't work this doesn't
make sense why you and they here's the
thing and this is what here's the thing
is Richard and Ryan who were Partners uh
and they wrote the script together they
listened to me they didn't hold on to
their script like it was gold or
something most people do that they [__]
this guy I don't want to deal with it
yes absolutely that's what happened to
me in Thailand they told me in in
Thailand oh yeah we're very interested
in being collaborative as far as the
script they weren't I went over there
and they you know um they they just
weren't but these guys did these guys
did and so they listened to me a lot so
I was really able to create the
character that I and it was like I said
it was a pretty good script and first of
all I said you got to change the title I
mean unless you want to be do shark NATO
you know you can't call zaru that's
ridiculous yeah it's called the red
which is much better it's about well the
red is the biggest uh kangaroo in
Australia so they get to be about six
seven feet five or six feet anyway right
and you know kangaroos if you Google
nasty looking kangaroos just one that
aren't even in movies they're they're
[__] some nasty looking kangaroos Who
Stare right at you they're all buff
they're all they look like they've been
lifting weights I think they get chia or
is that koalas koalas that's koalas but
they so anyway we you know we started uh
talking about it and uh they they they
they Sho they were going to shoot at all
location in Australia they put an
Australian U crew together in a cast and
uh then some like torrential rains hit
it you know and it it got pushed back
and I was in Australia at that point
that's why I went to go do the thing in
Thailand I went to do the thing in
Thailand and I came back to do this and
um but you know I think they lost a lot
of their a lot of the budget was lost
because you know these these rains hit
and they they had it all cast and
everything and then they had to turn
around and recast it and um so anyway
you finished the movie yeah yeah we did
the movie but Michael it it it was so by
the time that we were shooting it the
budget was so small I mean this is a
monster you could have spent $20 million
on it okay um the budget was minuscule I
mean minuscule there are times that you
would look at the lunch table you know
at night with [__] a lot at nights and
there would be the director his partner
Richard the writer uh talking to him
about shots they needed to get a DP his
name is uh uh Bland wow I think of his
first name I called well I started
calling him blond blond I thought his
name was blonde and then I started
calling him Blondie and then I was
started started
Blondie you know from the Clint Eastwood
movies but there's only a few people at
this table uh lunch yeah like seven and
you're used to I mean you've done huge
no listen listen when I did I did um
earlier this year before the writers
went out I did a law and order right and
worked um uh with Maloney uh Christopher
M he's he's awesome by the way what a
horse he is what a what a you know he
has that 40 40 Teamsters on that show
okay 40 Teamsters are working on that
show we had like you know we had the guy
the DP shot at himself and it was just
him no gaffer
uh kind of kind of yeah some holding one
the screen no no doesn't seem like there
were any lights out there they would
just hold up screens and it wasn't
frustrating to you no man I had a great
character I you know it was like it was
a great fun character crazy crazier than
a [__] loon um but you know I'm good
at crazy but usually the crazy people
that I play are they're bad also they
want to kill somebody or they want to
you know Johnny Ringo the guy played the
fan like all of those every bad guy I've
ever played a psychopath this guy's like
a Vietnam vet who's just like [__]
lost it but it's he's
crazy uh in in in a fun kind of way and
he's the one who originally knows what's
going on with this creature and comes
running into town oh my God I've seen it
I've seen it you know we're all in
Mortal danger and they're like H it's
Med character name is Schmitty oh it's
Schmitty again you know okay Schmitty
you saw a big kangaroo and yeah blah
blah blah you know flashback are you
buddy yeah exactly and then somebody
else gets killed oh no then then
somebody two uh miners get killed and
then a young boy gets killed don't give
the whole thing away I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm not but here's the thing about
it Michael that I
learned cuz um I'm a producer on the
show on on on it and um you know I saw
the rough cut and you know I felt pretty
good about the rough cut but rough cuts
are hard to watch because it doesn't
have the music it doesn't have the sound
design it doesn't like yeah they're
really very very hard to watch so anyway
they sent me the movie a couple of days
ago and uh uh it's
unbelievable how
good a little tiny movie it can be and I
don't mean tiny like it shot in one room
it's shot in Australia we shot it in the
bush you know got a low budgeted movie
in the middle of nowhere yeah dude it's
a really low budget movie and the crew
never seemed to be more than about 10
people uh and but they surrounded me
with um three or three or four really
really good actors and actresses and
actors and actresses no good scripts
when they see them and they you know and
that's why they're in it you know
there's a the W there's a woman who's
the star of it is kind of has to take
and I think her last name is pronounced
Harbaugh uh Tess is her name and she's
really really good in it very very good
it looks great um they are uh right now
they are uh they we you know um
festivals no we there no we're uh
talking to a company uh called shutter
which is I love shutter I own shutter
okay I watch all my horror movies there
all right well there we negoti why don't
we do a screening at my house well okay
you know I dude I love that [__] yeah
well you love you got to let me know
I'll love
it inside of you is brought to you by
discover if you like using debit over
credit don't you think it's time you
also get re rewarded well now you can
with discover cashback debit it's a
checking account that rewards everyone
with cashback on everyday purchases plus
there are no fees period we're talking
date nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends and it's
now earning you cash back with discover
cashback debit check out eligibility and
terms at discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member
FDIC it looks great it this camera guy
blonde this uh Chris bland is his name H
is unbelievable what he did they shot it
with one camera mon mov oh it does not
look there's not one shot in it that
looks low budget it's well
acted it's got a good soundtrack it's
well edited and it's short cuz these
days you don't need to make a you know
because of uh the streaming services you
can make an 80 8 Minute movie oh yeah 70
yeah well you you can I think this is 88
but you're critical you're you seem like
the kind of guy that if it was a piece
of shit' be like it's a piece of [__]
don't see it I wouldn't even I wouldn't
you I'm promoting this and because you
really like this I like it and I like it
and it's people don't realize when
they're going to see a movie that some
are made for a million and some are made
for 100 milon 100 million and usually
they suck uh well no uh I think the uh
The Avengers had problems this weekend
this past weekend uh and one of the
things that uh I've showed it to a
couple friends of mine that that kind of
like about it is there's there's some
CGI because the monster CGI but you can
tell we're in the bush we're out there
we're sweating it's dirty it's you know
um and um so I don't you know I don't
want to talk it up too much like I said
the budget on it is very very very
minimal you know that's it's funny cuz
my friend Bill who's helping me out
today who's one of my good friends he
wrote this awesome
movie uh let them die and it's a great
script and he's I've seen some of his
like short films it's amazing and I'm
like and we want to make this thing and
it's a movie like that that's just we
could do this lowbudget and really make
this
movie great and I believe in him and so
it's one of those things where you
believed in a young filmmaker that
didn't have a lot of money but you saw
something in there you worked on the
script it was collaborative they allowed
you to it was malleable yes and
ultimately you not only had a great time
and a great working relationship but you
like the movie as well yes that's that's
a rare thing but I commend you for like
taking these guys under your wing in a
way and like using your expertise and
your talent and your like notoriety or
whatever I couldn't have done it if they
wouldn't let me do it and
it's ego ego no I know what I'm doing
I'm not going to let if you want some oh
you've only been doing this for 50 years
you know I don't I don't think that you
know what you're talking you know it's
what I had the other one I did in
Thailand it's just like yeah we're not
interested in what you have to say
promoting that well I haven't seen it
okay wait to see let me ask you this and
listen when I do a show like that I'm
still committed and but I'm protecting
myself and I'm not going to say any
stupid [__] you know I'm not you want me
to say this I'm you know like I I'll
protect myself I'll be good in it I'll
be good in it but hopefully hopefully
you guys go with the rest of it the way
you thought it was so you know Cherry
you know when you were uh telling me uh
uh to go [__] myself with my
suggestions you know I want to ask you
one story that I heard and maybe it's
told a million times but I don't think
Ryan's heard it so let's do it for quiet
Ryan who's here to your left quiet Ryan
quiet Ryan over there he doesn't look
interested I know you're making notes
he's interested yeah are you interested
Ryan yeah yeah he is he doesn't have a
microphone when I watched he doesn't
have a microphone when I watched the
podcast back and I was making sure I
didn't say the same thing he just always
over there never looking at me just
always just [__] like doing that like
like he's not part of it you know he you
need to get him a mic well I normally do
we we have this weird setup so we have
to get a mic Ryan we have to figure this
out today we're going to figure it out
maybe is this the one that you asked how
is therapy was going last time I was
here your therapy and everything how's
your therapy going I don't [__] go I
don't I've been to I've been to so many
ther I you know my my son my wife and I
were in in in in Bisby about a month ago
and she said uh we're having dinner at
some restaurant she said you're ADHD
adult ADHD you know I'm like I'm not are
I'm not I've been to you know 10
psychiatrist I've been to like 30
therapists I've been to like a doctor
and AA meetings and like nobody's ever
said I'm ADHD they ever say you were
bipole or anything nothing uh no so they
they they they they I've had some nice
manic man I had epis yeah good but they
were fun they were well they're fun when
they're on the highs but when you hit
low not so fun I don't I didn't get the
low part I was over in France the George
sank I know if you know that hotel over
there just spending money I went over
there and made did something for 100,000
by the time I left the George shank was
all gone Jesus when was that I don't
know you can look it up on my IMDb page
25 oh was when you know 25 years ago I
was married to Gina I don't think I I
don't remember um anyway let's go back
to what the abyss I heard the story that
Ed Harris almost died cuz he ran out of
oxygen when he was swimming to one of
those tanks or something there there was
no oxygen and he barely made it is that
true I don't know you never heard about
that heard Ed tell it well when I say I
don't know I Ed you can go online and
listen to Ed talk about exactly what
happened to him and I think more than
anything else there was a mix up
underwater and a safety diver got to him
and didn't put uh the octopus in right
into his mouth and uh he sucked up some
and it happened to Jim Cameron too um
there was a time when we were shooting
we're in a 30ft tank and uh we're in the
bottom and we don't we you know we're
not in scoo scuba gear we got these
masks on we got weights on our feet and
it's kind of like you know you're
walking along it's kind of like being on
the moon you can kind of bounce around
and it was fun I really enjoyed that
movie I had a great time the only time
the only thing that I didn't like about
was I wasn't always on the set right you
know because I was playing the bad guy
so it was a lot of the other but what
about the boots stay with the boots uh
oh yeah so so anyway we're so so we're
working and you know they have lights
underwater however they figure that out
you know we're working and we've been
been doing it for weeks and weeks and
weeks at and working underwater and
doing different stuff and it's a huge
tank millions and millions and millions
of gallons of water and they put these
beads on the top because the light was
coming through and they Jim wanted to be
able to light it properly so they put
all these little tiny beads and it was
all black on top so no light would come
in and we're down there and uh we had an
underwater uh uh oxygen tank that you
just plug into and you get you fill up
your oxygen and then you you know then
you're off and you're wandering around
and until your shots ready you're
bouncing around you know I used to you
know I told you I was a wake and bit guy
for 40 years or whatever you know and I
I had a blast I had a great time
especially doing the underwater stuff um
but nothing happened so what happened
was like all of a sudden it just
everything went black like all they lost
all
power uh to and there
were F four three or four actors under
there the entire crew but they all have
scuba gear on they have sco they could
just you know no no and it it went from
like me talking to you to you like
closing your eyes I mean that's scary it
was it was weird weird I mean I have
oxygen but the first my your first
thought is well how much how much oxygen
did I have you know and then as time
goes by it's like it's dark I don't know
where we are I don't know how much
oxygen I have what the f is going on so
for you hear anything no of course not
underwater no I thought maybe they had
like
little no they did well Jim could talk
to us but no nobody was communicating
how long were you there I was we were
there for probably about 2 minutes which
seemed like eternity it seemed like a
long time and then I thought to myself
Michael you have a practical light on
you and a practical light is one that
your character would use in a movie they
call it a practical light right so I'm
like oh my god I've got my flashlight
deal so I pull that out I turn that on
and people started just coming towards
me you know because I was the only light
underneath there after two minutes of
people going what the [__] the safety di
came to you all the everybody all every
everybody everybody who was down there
came and because
nobody had one except for my practical
light and then Jim kind of rounded us
all out and with hand signals and stuff
said like you know follow me we're going
to go out this way and uh so like Jim
Cameron to the rescue as always he was
the man I mean if you're ever in a
foxhole you want to be in a foxhole with
that guy and uh you know nobody was
expecting it and it was scary it was
scary uh but um uh you know as as Jim
was leading the group and we were all we
all held each other we were all like
lined up holding each other and Jim was
you know he knew you know geographically
where he was and how to get out and uh
by the time you know 30 or 40 seconds of
doing that all of the sudden everything
all the lights came back on again so
that was that was a scary experience for
me that is crazy you know uh uh Ed uh
had an experience where I I think he
sucked up some water but what Ed Harris
who was by the way he was he's kind of a
real man's man kind of a guy he you know
you know I'd go out running he'd be like
hitting a speed you he'd be hitting a
bag you know i' I drive in in my
Mercedes he'd Drive In in his truck I'd
be smoking uh uh uh maror lights he'd be
smoking camels without without a filter
you know he was he was that guy he's a
great
actor wonderful guy and I think that uh
from what I've seen online or heard
online is that uh I've watched him talk
about it is he was disappointed in his
own
reaction to like a near-death
experience he was disappointed in in
himself the way that his brain went oh
[__] I'm going to die or whatever I'm
not sure I don't want to put words in
his mouth and that that more than
anything else you know Jim Cameron has
got an incredible record when you think
about the movies that he's done in water
the Terminator all the fighting all the
car chases all the shooting all the
effects all everything blowing up uh and
Aliens things are blowing up fire always
all over the place I don't nobody's ever
been h on a gym C here's another story
I'll tell you quickly and then you can
edit what you want to edit okay so uh
Jim is uh
I'm I'm working I believe I was working
on the Terminator with him at some point
in the Terminator and he's working on
the set and I I noticed a difference
about him I noticed that he wasn't his
he
wasn't himself and he seemed a little
bit distant as compared to the Jim
camerman who's in your face going I want
this and I want that you got it you got
it okay let's roll is everybody ready
all right let's roll you know he's
there's something that seemed a little
odd about him and uh at one point it was
in the morning I think at one point in
the morning I pulled him Jim are you
okay are you all right you seem he goes
I'm okay I said are you sure and he said
well you know Michael I wrote a
script
um uh for
um uh what's the Stallone movie where
he's out in the woods he's a Rambo Rambo
he wrote he wrote Rambo
to and you know I wrote a scene and I
just heard this morning or last night
that uh a stunt man was killed doing
that scene that I
wrote and uh I you know I said Jim like
what you know you can't blame yourself
for that but but he felt it he felt it
and so people that think Jim ceron is
just this like film making you know like
you know he's a he he's a compassionate
caring
person sometimes doesn't have time to
show it but that's a perfect example of
a thing that he was taking um he was
taking it on himself and I said to him
like and and and had to say Jim like you
can't blame yourself for that I'm not
sure that that helped the situation but
he
uh well he he he felt what happened to
him and it affected the way that he was
uh uh not performing but the way that he
was uh working the next day and I I saw
it Vis I knew him well enough at the
time that I next time I come back I'll
tell you the story about what happened
on Aliens and how I got paid more for
them to use my IM they tried to use my
image without my permission and David
Fincher yeah who basically says nobody
hates that movie more than me and um but
they tried to use my image without my
permission and it it it was a whole big
deal they ended up paying me as much as
I made for the movie to use a picture of
me to kill me off good for you well
there's and there's a whole story behind
it well we're going to save it okay man
this has been awesome do you have fun I
always have fun dude it's so good Ryan
do you have fun I did yeah all right we
get him a microphone yeah thanks Mike
yeah you're
welcome you know he was was worried he
was like I don't know man I don't know
if it's going to be as good they just
had me on there you know you I was just
on your podcast well it'll be a year
yeah you think people want to listen I'm
like yeah they do so he came on and I
think he's uh I think this one this is
great I think people are going to love
this one because he's just so likable
and his stories are so freaking good man
thank you Michael
beantree thank you Michael beus thank
you Michael be there done
that I always say I've been they done
that anyway thanks it was awesome um and
thanks for supporting the podcast guys
this is a real treat again if you want
to give back to the podcast you can go
to
patreon.com inside you and join patreon
and get back and really help the podcast
and I'll try to write you a little note
thank you and there's so many great
perks you get your names shouted out at
the end of every episode what you're
about to do what you're about to do
woohoo yes very exciting Ryan very
exting OB excited yes um any new shows
you've been watching new shows anything
I've been watching the Pacific I know
it's dated oh that's an old one I know
but I hadn't seen it and it's pretty
good yeah that's you know it's not as
like engaging with like the characters
that you really like sometimes I don't
really recognize like who I'm following
and it it's a little bit all over but
it's cool
uhhuh uh I just rewatched the good place
I love the good place yeah um I don't
know if that's for you though but n it's
probably not for me I you know I watched
an episode and I thought they were both
Charming hell was cool just not my kind
of show but it's a good show I'm sure
it's a good show I'm just really
critical and I hate that about myself
I'm too critical but if I wasn't
critical then I'd probably just like oh
my gosh NCI Albuquerque was unbelievable
last night there's one in Sydney now do
you know that there's not one in
Albuquerque though is there uh no thank
God I just let him went well NCI well
it's Naval Base so I don't think
Albuquerque would do well with a naval
show it's a naval show NCIS I didn't
know that that's what it stands for what
Navy CIS
Navy Corporation
intelligence is it Navy intelligence
crime crime Investigative Services no
I'm kidding yeah crime investigations
who cares here we go these are the top
tier patrons we're going to read out
these are people that get back to the
podcast that I consider friends and I
love you and thank you uh Ryan can read
with me okay
Nancy D sweet Nancy D Leah and Kristen
little Lisa Yuko Jill e Brian H Nico P
how's Zach doing I hope he's doing all
right Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike E Elon Supremo 99 more San Diego M
lean
P Maddie s Belinda n Dave H wait wait
Dave H it's Dave H hey Michael it's Dave
h
Dave Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom
n Talia M Betsy d ranan c Cory
K Dev nexton Michelle a Jeremy Cy D
Brandy D Eugene and Leah I love you
Corey Mel s Christine s Eric H Shane R
Andrew M Amanda R Kevin e Stephanie K
Jerel jam and J lean J Luna R Mike F
Stonehenge Brian
L uh Jules M Kendall L Jessica B Kyle F
Marisol P Kaylee J Brian a Mary and
Louise L Romeo the band Frank B J T
Nikki L April R Randy s jdw oral oral P
Oral B Rachel D Melissa H Nick W
Stephanie and Evans Charlene a Don G
Jenny B John Jennifer R Tina e NG Tracy
and juny guys I adore the crap out of
you thank you so much and um from the
Hollywood Hills in California I'm
Michael Rosen bomb I'm Ryan Taz wave to
the camera uh we love you be good to
yourself all right be good to
[Music]
yourself